what are some of the things that have
always bothered you or puzzled you
anybody
yeah I don't know why doing the
boundaries on love friendship desire
Oh God sir that's a good one boundaries
yeah
you can you can approach that in
different ways and you can ask what does
it actually mean to put a boundary you
can say well when should we do it or
when shouldn't we do it other different
cases and already we're moving into
different areas of philosophy under
doing it how do you know that you're
making the right choices with the
boundaries that's that's part of
epistemology you might actually Ford
asking that question you have to delve
into human nature a bit you know to get
a good idea about that that's a very
concrete question that's not like what
is being you know that's that's very
specific in its generality which might
say if you want to be paradoxical what
are other things that puzzled you I
think relationships are something that
done do puzzle us quite a bit what else
yeah there always have to be some sort
of common ground above the friendship
well that's a good one yeah
well we'll talk about that and when we
actually start digging into friendship
again I would fit into philosophy of
human nature into ethics to a certain
degree you might also ask questions like
that the friends have to know that they
have a common ground how do you know
that you have the common ground with
somebody else
what does what does it mean to have
common ground you've probably had some
experiences in your life I'm willing to
bet where you thought there was common
ground and it turned out that that you
were interested in the same basic thing
if they had a very different take on it
than you did and maybe the friendship
ended at that point what else there are
other things that positive
irritated you or amazed you yeah oh okay
that's a big one yeah you can move on to
things like aha should we actually live
treat each other think about things yeah
is there ever such a thing as a 100
percent selfless act oh that's good too
certainly a lot of people talk like it
don't they
and yeah now we're starting to get into
something that they often call
philosophical psychology you know
exploring what makes us tick
Jeremy end up somebody did over there
who else
it's quite a few of you here yet what is
rooh
oh yeah that's that's a big one now that
fits into metaphysics and it also fits
into what we call philosophy of the
action and that's what really that's
that's a big one to get out of the way
isn't it and if we don't have any free
will there's a lot of other things that
we probably don't need to think about
but if we do have free will then there's
a lot of other issues that flow from
them like when are we actually free how
responsible are we what else how about
one more I wanna start the shtick about
here's this here's that any other big
yet what that's a good one yeah that
would interestingly not fit in with
ethics if you can see the Veth explain
oh I think that's something that's
pretty important for you guys here as
students especially at the beginning of
your career to think about what counts
as success for you here I mean a lot of
people want to measure with grades and
you guys have you know I'm guessing most
of you've gotten pretty good grades so
far been praised for they had or
rewarded for that and you've got the
idea that it's important to get good
grades and I'm not knocking good grades
okay but but you're going to realize
that grades don't really translate into
success
and they don't translate into having
learned or having lasting knowledge or
developing talents there's a there's
some connection but there's there's a
big disconnect between the two of them
so you know what's actually going to be
success for for you you're a lot more
likely to reach that form of success
whatever it happens to be if you
actually have some idea of it rather
than just sort of you know proceeding
willy-nilly and hoping that things fall
into place
it's kind of an aside a couple
generations ago your grandparents
generation they probably actually could
people that are called the baby boomers
they could more or less blunder through
things and things that turn out okay
college was cheap back then work was
plentiful you know America was sort of
riding high on a crest of prosperity and
it's been tougher for my generation much
tougher and it's going to be much much
tougher for your generation we're
reverting back to where the rest of the
world is most of the most of history
where it's not quite so easy so figuring
out what kinds of success for you is it
having you know the top job is it having
a good family life is it meeting the
person who you were destined to to be
with the rest of your life and falling
in love and doing all those sorts of
things those may not be all compatible
with each other and so you probably do
want to think out those sorts of things
and we do that in philosophy in
different now I'm going to put a lot of
words on the board and we don't have
enough room on the board they actually
put some of the questions under them so
you're going to Center remember these
and some of these will be words that are
derived from Greek because philosophy in
the West begins in in Greece for
instance this word metaphysics
metaphysics literally means that which
comes after physics in part because
Aristotle's work that's entitled the
metaphysics came after his work that's
entitled the physics in his corpus but
but now it's come to mean something a
bit more specific
you know 2,000 years later at 2,300
years later here's another one that's
coming from Greek wisdom ology the word
of pista may means knowledge or
something that's a discipline like are
any of you going into psychology here so
that's a that's an epistemology bout
might also be what we call a tech name
it craft that's a different matter
here's another one that you probably
didn't realize it's coming from ethics
comes from a 'those character also the
another closely related where the means
happen because for the ancient Greeks a
lot of what we do is a product of our
habits so we need to look closely at our
habits and see what kind of people we
make ourselves into what kind of
characters we develop here's another one
also they come from Greek logos it is a
word that can mean about 20 different
things in Greek ranging from word to
account to fiction to story but it can
also mean reason and it can mean
arguments it can be in a constructed you
know set going from some beginning
points premises all the way to a
conclusion with some inferences along
the way and that's what logic tries to
to examine sort of the rules of good
thinking of proper entrance how we
different point A to point B so these
are some big areas but you know they
don't cover all the things that we're
interested in
if we start looking at some of the big
questions that they ask there is some
other questions about how we want to
live or who ought to hold power that we
put under social and political
philosophy
what is power what is power over another
person often times ethics and social and
political philosophy get lumped together
in a big catch-all called value fields
right because they deal with human
values good and bad right and wrong just
and unjust fair and unfair legal and
illegal are there any other things that
we tend to have value judgments about
that you can pick up there's good and
bad right wrong that's not all that we
are concerned with is it let's think
about music for example how many of you
like music how many of you have iPods or
you know something that plays in
Petrie's every one of you how did you
decide what goes in there did you
evaluate everything on the basis of
ethics this song is very uplifting it's
going to make me a better person I'll
put that on there this song no this
would make me a bad person to listen to
it is that when you evaluate what you
you listen to maybe a few I don't know
maybe some people but how do you
evaluate it what do you what makes you
what prompts you besides you know how
there's a popular ban
get them to listen how did you know were
your taste
your taste as an individual
okay yeah I mean if you're oftentimes we
pick up the music and other people that
we like listen to right that may
actually be the basis for some
friendships it was for me a nice yeah we
absorb our background sometimes they're
tied in with warm fuzzy memories - Dan
used to listen to this song when we were
washing a car you know our good nice
associations but after a while you start
to especially when you become an adult
you start to make your own path when it
comes to that
music is one of the great consumer
commodity items for us by which we
choose our environment we don't realize
what a massive choice we have compared
to people you know generations ago who
we're stuck with whatever the musicians
back there we're gonna play or whatever
it was on the jukebox I mean you can
walk around with literally thousands of
songs and listen to anything you want at
any given time that opens up a whole
field of what we call aesthetics and
aesthetics has to do with art but I
wanted to begin with an example that is
much more down-home easy to relate to
that you know I going to the art gallery
and staring at a painting and saying
what does it mean is it moving me
because we don't do that that often
doing I'm not knocking art by the way
I'm just saying in our culture if you
want to look at our ordinary experience
music is what we make aesthetic
decisions about the most
this band sucks why mother's derivative
of this other game you've made another
aesthetic judgment you said that being
derivative is not as valuable as being
what creative original something like
that
you have lapsed into the world of
aesthetics whether you realize it or not
what else should I put up here right now
let me mention loss the human nature
which is what we call a philosophical
anthropology amp you know anthropos is
human being ecology you don't let me
study up right so philosophical
anthropology means to study the question
what does it mean to be a human being
what are the basic things that connect
us all up together I mean it's nice to
say human being is the rational animal
but what does it really mean when you
unpack it
that's what philosophical anthropology
would do it would look at questions like
what is the will free you know do we
have free will as well would fit under
philosophical anthropology as well as
other places so let's stick with these
for just a moment and look at some of
the big questions that they asked
let's take logic logic asks things like
how should we argue how should we put
you know together the claims that we
make along with the justifications for
those claims and the modes of inference
how do we know that we're actually
inferring things the right way and there
aren't rules for some of these things
and I give you some of that 9 learn you
can study logic as an independent
discipline there's there's a lot of
stuff there actually its basis gets very
close to mathematics interestingly
enough when I was an undergraduate I was
particularly interested in logic
the foundations of mathematics and I did
a lot of work in that and then I ended
up leaving that behind in part because I
felt it was kind of sterilized more more
interested in these sorts of things but
but there's a lot there and we're not
going to be exploring logic thematically
in this class but we will be using it
and I'll try to point that out to you
over the course of the semester you know
every time that we look at an argument
we're in a way doing some logic you're
saying you know put it put aside what
the arguments about is the argument the
way it's set up a good argument or a bad
argument if you're asking that question
you're asking a question that's
concerned with logic there's other
things that can get tied in with it
depending on what your conception of
logic logic is but I don't want to get
too deep into that let's move over here
to metaphysics
now when I say metaphysics what is it
what does that call the mind because we
do have some cultural assumptions about
that so something's metaphysical
was it just like I think keep keep away
sign
people laughing well it's metaphysics
you know whether that's left there are
some people who claim to be doing thanks
or they say they're doing something
metaphysical I remember when I when I
was in graduate school one of the first
classes I took this was a mess physics
class and the instructor at the
beginning of the class the very first
day he he was this British guy and he
said now I want to make this really
plain to all of you that we're not going
to be talking about crystals here or
wavelengths or things of that sort of
nature psychic readings that's some
people do call that metaphysics but what
we're doing here is philosophical
metaphysics we're looking at other sorts
of things
so it's not these things although they
do have a basis if you dig deep enough
those beliefs about those do have a
basis in somebody's metaphysics what
metaphysics is examining is the nature
of reality so when you've got into
debates about what's real and what's not
real with somebody you've been doing
some metaphysics whether you realize
that or not whether you called it that
or not right the the difference between
appearance and reality that's a
metaphysical question what what makes
things you know work the way that they
actually work that that's a metaphysical
question how are things put together is
there some sort of one primal substance
that everything is made up or maybe it's
atoms you know or nowadays you know we
break it down further and for any of
particles and that you know start coming
up with quarks and you know maybe two
generations from now we'll have
something lower level than that is that
the basic building block of everything
other questions - what is time
that's a tricky question one of the guys
you're going to read this semester said
you know that's one of those questions
where I think I can't the answer down
pat until you actually start asking me
and putting me on the spot and then
suddenly I realize that all the
explanations that I have just totally
unwrapped I don't I have no idea what
I'm talking about
I was Saint Augustine the end his book
about time he says that because time is
Canada a tricky thing you know if you
think about those movies that you see
where there's time-travel involved and
paradoxes about what if I kill my
grandfather is a can alter history or
like cease to exist
that's a metaphysical question or think
about another can movie could this all
be the matrix that's in part an
epistemological question but that's also
a metaphysical question because what
what do you remember what the matrix is
made of what was the basic substratum
or is that movie getting to be a little
bit too old for ya oh I thought you're
raising your hand that's ok how many of
you see the matrix so not everybody yeah
I guess we can't use that as sort of a
common touch point anymore
those of you who has seen it remember it
and you know putting aside although you
know dodging bullets
you've come foodstuff what would be
really about who remember those scary
guys the ones who could like fight
everybody and Keanu Reeves finding kills
one at the end of the first one what
were what were those guys they're agents
of God
my god yeah robots yeah I mean they were
robots except they weren't corporeal
were they because where was all this
taking place yeah exactly
in computer things I mean there were you
know all these people plugged in to this
gigantic set of tubes and sloshing
bathtubs I guess they set up his
batteries you know so there was that
metaphysical thing but but the the
reality that they were experience was a
virtual reality so if we ask questions
like is virtual reality also real or you
could ask us about dreams too if you die
you know people have the thing you
remember this like in middle school if
you die in your dream you die in real
life there are movies that 1980s they're
really fascinated with this question as
a Nightmare on Elm Street all those
movies were coming out the levels are
metaphysical themes I don't know if you
ever thought about that but you're
dealing with metaphysical things pista
mala G is is kind of connected with
metaphysics it has to do with knowledge
and with truth and a certainty how can
we be certain about things what degree
of certainty can be achieved
those are epistemological questions so
are any of you for example going into
say criminal justice ok you will be
dealing with epistemological questions
all the time whether you're
a cop or a parole officer or counselor
or a guard or you know an officer over
these people you're going to be dealing
with this this epistemological problem
how do you tell who's lying to you and
who's telling the truth that's a big
issue isn't it can you imagine trying to
imagine trying to be a cop and having no
sense about who's lying and who's that
how long do your career last unless
somebody's like covering you on your so
insoles nephew they give you all the
using cases but those are those are
cosmological problems there's other
epistemological problems like the the
matrix one how do we know that we're
actually not in a dream or in a virtual
reality or something like that's an
epistemological problem what is nink
what is the nature of knowledge what
goes on when we actually have knowledge
and water may be second best things to
knowledge like right opinion those are
all epistemological questions do you see
the the connection and also the
difference between these field it's
starting to coalesce Oriya ethics now
when I say the word ethics what comes to
your mind yeah that's that's usually how
we put it or rules morals yeah a lot of
people want to say ethics is one thing
morals is another and I don't do that
because in history of philosophy that's
not the case it's an arbitrary
distinction people want to say sometimes
well there's moral codes and there's
ethics a moral code is an ethics a moral
code is is telling you how you want to
act a lot of the professions that you
guys are likely training for you know
criminal justice is one of them there is
you know criminal justice ethics as a
field how many of you are planning on
doing a business or accounting
so there's business on this they're
actually putting together a course on
that which you might be interested
taking if it's if it's up and running by
the time of you guys are doing it
although I like having business majors
in my class they contribute a lot to it
any of your going to be doing
communication there's communication
outlets journalism ethics medical ethics
all sorts of things every profession has
some sort of code out there not that a
lot of them necessarily live up to it
but they have some sort of code some
ideals about how you ought to behave
well former student of mine from Maris's
right now engaged in a legal ethics
class and he was he was one of my
nothing students and so he was telling
me about some of the stuff that they're
they're studying and he's finding it
fascinating and he's really fighting it
fascinating how hard it is to to walk
the line of doing you know everything
that the code requires and being a good
lawyer interesting ethical question what
else do you think ethics might may
include so there's right wrong rules
codes
there's other stuff that you get worried
about that actually fits into ethics in
the way that we do it philosophy yeah
like how what you deal with ones
underneath will affect some consequences
yeah that's important what about the
question of how should I run my life
what's a good life and what's of damaged
or an imperfect or ruined life those are
ethical questions at least they were for
the Greeks do I need friends or don't
any friends that's an ethical question
that fits into this broad domain of
ethics I'm not going to go into too many
because I know I get to some of these
other things we talked about aesthetics
aesthetics ask questions like what is
beauty what makes something art I mean
can I just you know what makes it work
right now all right we got a found
object and I'm going to sign my name on
it there you go work of art right you
want to buy it anybody you know fifty
bucks
now used to want to buy it probably done
right
fifty cents I don't think it's even
worth that but but all sure for fifty
cents now if you were if you were if you
got a reaction you're like that's BS
that's the art you were having you're
making aesthetic judgment and there's
there's reasons why this is not art I
don't believe this is lard you don't
think it's are either right okay you're
just doing that for the sheer
entertainment value right that
entertainment by the way fits on your
studies what's good entertainment what's
bad entertainment these are all
questions that have to do with a very
important part of our lives that we
often don't think of in terms of
philosophy what makes a person
attractive that's an aesthetics question
what makes a person ugly all physical or
is there some component to the soul to
it can a person have an ugly personality
that's an aesthetic question it also
ties in with not fixed to some degree
political and social philosophy you can
think of it as like ethics but but tying
in with bigger questions like how should
our society be organised who should run
the show
who should you know get to vote who
shouldn't get to vote John Stuart Mill
for example if you're not going to read
this semester he actually thought me
Americans were totally crazy he was all
for democracy but you know we give
everybody one vote that's nuts
you should give everybody intelligence
tests and if somebody has like twice the
intelligence of somebody else they
should get two folks if somebody's dumb
given me a like a half a vote right um
that's an issue in social and political
philosophy I remember when I did a blog
entry about that and I wasn't saying
that mill was right I was mentioning
that people were incensed because I felt
that's that's anti-democratic that's a
social and political philosophy question
what else we talked about philosophy
human nature there's a lot of philosophy
up stuff what are some topics that
people get in debates about that maybe
philosophy would have something to say
in that yeah
oh yeah well let me put that one off
until the the stuff about love and
friendship and desire but let's think
about this one so one of the things
you're not supposed to talk about at you
know the dinner table a nice
conversation politics is one of them
right what else yeah yeah now there is
what we call philosophy put that down
here so I have to write what I'm doing
all these philosophies of religion what
do we do in that we don't we don't take
a stance like well I'm raised in this
tradition so therefore I'm going to
argue for that tradition we explore
questions like what is religion can you
actually define religion one of the
religions have in common
is there a God as their gods can you
make an argument one way or another we
deal with questions like well let's say
there is a God and he's actually you
know with what people generally say he
is you know omniscient omnipotent and
all good why the kid died in the street
the other day why is there evil those
are questions for the philosophy of
religion and philosophy religion is tied
in with metaphysics and with some of
these other fields as well
are there other things you could get wax
philosophical about
yeah what are other big concerns for
everything
I'll give you a hint put aside the fact
that we're doing philosophy here
what are we engaged
yeah oftentimes we call a political
economy so that confited there but you
could have philosophy of economics I
knew a guy who specialized in that what
are we doing here what's supposed to be
happening here yeah education yeah so
there is in fact the well-established
field tell the philosophy of education
some some you know philosophers if we're
going to read this semester like Plato
and Aristotle contributed massively to
that the neck quite so influential on
contemporary education that be more say
like John Mui who by the way did not
invent the Dewey Decimal System that's a
different duty guy but John Dewey
influenced American education there's a
lot of different philosophical take some
what is actually going on in learning
happens how should you how should you
teach what should the teacher be like
now some of that probably fits into
ethics and some of that probably fits
into political philosophy as well
there's some overlap here
what about science - signage actually
fully understand what they're up to
whether they sometimes get so narrowed
in on their little portion of what
they're studying that they lose sight of
the big picture this happens sometimes
not only with the Natural Sciences but
also the social sciences in a for
example where did sociale are anybody
doing sociology studying sociology or
psychology where did these disciplines
come from originally No
before Freud came on the scene
he was a psychoanalyst too just a
psychologist they came out of La Salette
philosophy is the mother many
disciplines combed one of the fathers of
sociology well he was a philosopher and
so you know why is that the case well
because a lot of the big questions that
you're approaching it what is science
what is scientific method these are
things that philosophers think about a
lot of scientists do as well or you know
questions like you know what about
science and religion are they totally
incompatible a lot of scientists and a
lot of religious people don't think very
deeply about these sort of things
knee-jerk reactions philosophers will
often think quite a bit about them you
may not have thought in this one there's
philosophy of language what is language
how does it work are there good music
for example be a language those are
questions in the philosophy of language
what is the definition that's what
question the philosophy of language
going to the question of free will that
ties in with a broader cube which is
really kind of a mix of philosophy of
human nature and metaphysics that we
call the philosophy of action what
motivates us human beings and a lot of
ways is connected together with
psychology is but this could be a great
application for people in business for
people in criminal justice really any
place where you've got to figure out
what makes people tick and what you know
channels their capacities to what degree
are they able to make choices or not
make choices how do human actions
actually happen that's that's part of
the philosophy of action now we could
read a lot of other things up here we
could write philosophy of technology we
can write philosophy of mathematics
really any field that you go into you're
going to find that as you move up in the
field you're asking more and more
philosophical questions more and more
questions that are broad in scope that
we often tie in
essentially as we say with who we are as
human beings the things that we're
really you know concerned with the
things that our situations impose upon
us and things that that people are there
questions on which there are many
different answers in part because it's
not as if everybody agrees about them
and you can even ask the question why
doesn't everybody agree that might be a
philosophical question that you want to
explore as time goes up some people
probably have a better idea about some
of these things you know if in
metaphysics you think that we're all
made out of celery sticks you're free to
have that opinion but you're probably in
a philosophical school of one all by
yourself on that one right if you think
everything is made out of atoms that's a
starting point that a lot of people
would go if you think that people have a
soul or don't have a soul there's
arguments one way or another
those are philosophically reputable
positions again if you think souls are
made out of celery sticks I've never
heard of anybody ever saying something
like that and it seems kind of silly to
begin with you're probably not going to
make it too far doing this sort of thing
now as you go on with your career you're
going to run into philosophical
questions and what I've done here is
give you some of the terminology to be
able to recognize that what it happens